the tomorrow war is thought-provoking
sci-fi
at its best as with any sci-fi this
ambitious a few questions remain
unanswered once the credits roll here
are just some of the questions to ponder
after watching the tomorrow war
while time travel can be fickle and
messy it's also intricate
and unfathomable if humans can figure
out a way to time travel then
surely higher tech weapons would be
available for the humanity defining war
against extraterrestrials
dan forrester played by chris pratt and
his fellow soldiers are given guns that
seemingly fire
modern day bullets then they're thrown
into battle to fight an enemy they know
nothing about
tasked with eradicating formidable
aliens multiplying at an unimaginable
rate
future humans are outnumbered and using
weapons that seem like they're throwing
pebbles at an attacking animal
luckily future murie is a genius and
comes up with a toxin to kill the aliens
and dan takes the toxin back to the past
locating the creatures when they light
dormant and
killing them before the war can take
place in the future so if the future can
build a wormhole
surely it can create better weapons the
conscripted soldiers and civilians are
expected to believe that time travel
exists
while at the same time accepting that
military-grade weaponry uses the same
ammo
30 years later in the future the global
population is in trouble because of the
war against aliens
the future responds by recruiting
soldiers from the past but not every
person who's drafted has military
experience or even knows how to load a
gun
the only qualification appears to be
that draftees have to have already died
by 2051
the year of the war two of the same
people can't exist at the same time we
are told or else a time paradox will
ensue
we are you 30 years
in the future the future has somehow
created a machine that can determine if
and when
someone died oddly yuri forester exists
in both
timelines she's a child in the present
and an adult in the future
but why is miri the only character that
naturally appears in the present and
future
all the present-day characters that
appear in the future are dead
all the future people can appear in the
past because they have yet to be born
which keeps the time paradox at bay
on the one hand the world's population
which is currently about 7.6 billion in
real life
is down to half a million which means
only a tiny sliver of humans are still
alive
and sure you can probably surmise that
other present soldiers children might be
among the future residents
on the other hand murray being the only
character who appears on both ends of
the time jumping
seems odd almost as if it's not a
coincidence
future murray forester becomes a
scientist in honor of her father
in the future she's the world's last
hope however
since we watched dan successfully lead a
mission to kill the aliens once he
returns to the past
does murray's life trajectory change the
aliens supposedly
no longer invade earth which likely
means that although murie wanted to
follow in her dad's footsteps
she will no longer grow up with the same
sense of urgency to become a scientist
and save the world if there's one thing
that the world needs right now
it's scientists since any change during
time travel can have a catastrophic
effect on the timeline
there is no guarantee that dan grows
apart from his family
dies in a car accident or inspires his
daughter to save the world
which actually might all be good things
after dan is drafted to fight in the war
and the military places the device on
his arm the military makes it clear that
his wife will have to take his place if
he decides to run
dodging the draft is a major offense
even in a sci-fi movie like the tomorrow
war
that said when dan asks his father james
if he can take the device off his arm
this appears to be something he does
with regularity
how does the old man pull this off
shouldn't the government have detected
the devices being taken off other people
whom do the devices belong to why does
james have them
while he seems like a crafty person who
lives off the grid
the movie dances around the fact that he
has collected these arm devices
despite the military telling dan that if
he runs or takes off the device they'll
find him
that all makes it sound as if the
consequence is inevitable
not to mention these devices must be
super high tech as they help enable a
person to transport to
and from the future when the military is
testing dan to see if he's an adequate
soldier for the war
a certificate of death is revealed that
says he'll die at age 47
seven years from the present because of
this realization dan is considered a
match for the future war
since it's implied that past events
change the future what happens to dan
after the war is stopped does he still
die in seven years
also unexplained is what made him become
such a different person
becoming unhappy with his life divorcing
his wife and doing exactly what his
father did to him
by leaving his family behind his
daughter reveals all this information
but never delves into the motivations
that made them happen beyond saying
you just never you never seemed happy
with your life
since the tomorrow war ends on a happy
note it's assumed that dan
rewrote his future he won't abandon his
family and he won't get into an accident
that leads to his death
although how do you avoid an inevitable
car accident just stop
driving would life eventually make it
happen anyway final destination style
what we do know is that dan's death
certificate was created
and the date of that event is still
seven years in the future
that said dorian's story was rewritten
instead of dying of cancer he died while
blowing up the alien ship
so maybe dan doesn't die in a car
accident but instead lands that dream
science job he's always wanted
people from the future are young in the
present timeline because
as dan and charlie conclude
however when the wormhole closes it
appears that future soldiers are stuck
in the present as the portal can't be
reopened
this is why the only way to stop the war
from occurring is to find where the
aliens are hiding during the present day
so are future soldiers stuck in the past
even though they've never been born
wouldn't that wreak havoc on innumerable
timelines
the jump link just went offline we can't
send anything back
time in this universe is like a river
that flows in one
steady direction and the jump link
places two rafts on this river which are
30 years apart
both rafts continue to travel along the
river time continues to pass yet the
jump link only allows people to jump
from one raft to the other
time only flows in one direction it's
like a river
although this concept explains why
people can't time travel to different
periods
and can only travel to the period where
each raft is located
it doesn't explain how unborn people can
get stuck in the past
when the future they came from no longer
happens the tomorrow war is careful not
to create a time paradox
but it avoids this question once dan
stops the aliens from attacking the
future is presumably erased
people can't live in both timelines at
the same time presumably not all the
future soldiers die as only a handful
were part of dan's mission
so can the unborn soldiers who survived
be born again in the future
wouldn't that create a time paradox can
the wormhole open back up if it can
what will the future look like can the
unborn soldiers return to their correct
timelines
the future should still exist in this
reality since the portal simply closed
and it can presumably be opened again or
does the fact that it closed mean the
future is lost
forever and there is only one raft left
on the river there's plenty of reasons
why they can't make a new one
immediately
the jump links are 30 years apart and
keep moving forward
you can only jump from one raft to the
other
more rafts can't be built because
they're held together poorly
the future barely managed to make one
rudimentary wormhole
if they weren't about to be extinct
they'd still be testing it with lab rats
all that aside now that there isn't a
global threat
surely the scientists will have more
time to understand the wormhole
make it safer more reliable and expand
on it this wormhole helped save the
world so that's not a technology that
sound minds would forget
it seems quite likely that the remaining
people in the future could resurrect the
tech
and once again connect to the past if
these people are intelligent enough to
create a wormhole in the first place
they should be able to do it again
and this time perhaps add more
destinations as well
thanks to dan's volcano loving student
in the present timeline his crew locates
where the aliens are hiding
as it turns out the aliens have been
here the whole time and dug
upwards to the surface after being
frozen for about a thousand years they
are due to complete this process at some
point around 2048 in russia
so dan and his crew must preempt that by
ambushing them in the present day
to do so they fly to russia undetected
which seems like an implausible feat
given that in the film
humanity is on the edge of collapse and
rioting in the streets in the belief
death will be coming soon
james might be a very talented pilot but
seriously how did he fly a plane into
russia without a single person detecting
it on the radar
his previously established skills and
staying off the grid and helping others
do the same
is supposed to make this believable but
it still seems to be a stretch
the tomorrow war is a film about heroes
who find a way to win at all costs but
this heroism seems like it had a little
movie magic sprinkled on top
roger that after dan's crew
locates the alien ship in russia they
break into it and discover two dead
pilot creatures hanging from the ceiling
that aren't white spikes
but they certainly aren't humans either
unlike the aliens they have been
battling which are carnivorous and
only appear to eat and reproduce the
pilot creatures appear more advanced
they're capable of building and flying a
ship
and it appears keeping the white spikes
safe and some sort of preserving goo
of course they weren't that good at
flying however as they most likely
crash-landed on earth
perhaps these creatures created the
white spikes or are a mutation of them
the audience will probably never know
when it comes to the white spikes
countless questions remain
how did the spaceship crash in russia
what were they looking for
what were they running from was earth
even their target
humans have long been obsessed with
possible life out there in the universe
and the tomorrow war firmly says it
exists but the more you speculate about
such things the more
follow-up questions present themselves
the aliens may have been looking for
resources
as they treated our world like an
all-you-can-eat buffet but what would
they have done once they ate every last
human and animal
remember it only took them three years
to have us on the verge of extinction so
these guys are hungry
perhaps most importantly are we really
sure every last white spike was killed
visibility in that snow was pretty bad
and blowing up their ship
doesn't guarantee their extinction from
earth if the female white spike was
temporarily able to escape
who's to say another one didn't
unknowingly flee who's to say there
wasn't another female white spike on
board or even worse
a second ship buried elsewhere perfectly
giving us the premise for a sequel
perhaps the biggest unanswered question
from the tomorrow war
is what other life exists in this
universe the white spikes have tentacles
that shoot spikes
fangs that chew through human flesh like
soft cheese and an exterior virtually
immune to bullets
they are predators and humans weren't
their first meals which implies that
they eat other creatures as well
in all likelihood there's another life
form beyond the white spikes and perhaps
the pilots in the universe of the
tomorrow war
so while humans celebrate they might
also want to cross their fingers and
hope that dan forrester is around to
help for longer than seven more years
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one